we're here in the most amazing kitchen
the massive kitchen cuz tonight is the
premiere of MasterChef junior eight
seven central on Fox mm-hmm I can't wait
for the premiere season seven the best
but we'll kick this one off with a
little challenge I'm gonna challenge my
compadre the Mexican James Bond indeed
Jaime like me ha me the Mexican James
Bond that has a beautiful chef we're
going to go to set a record let's see
how many peanut butter and jelly
sandwich you can make in 60 seconds I
grew up with peanut butter jelly you
know oh I guess ideas but I do like
being peanut butter a jam or jelly I
think they're wonderful the combinations
are endless with the kind of jam you can
use doctor each other but you have tech
over breakfast nachos tacos for
breakfast yes I see I see no from me all
day long pretty yes get the day started
get some energy in you let's go
can we have 60 seconds of the popcorn
okay um you know I mean massive jr. is
one of the most exciting can come
together on the planet and we're very
competitive with them they're very
competitive us but I'm more competitive
with this man because you he is he's a
secret weapon yeah Mexico yep he's now
getting this global phenomenon worldwide
reputation yes indeed for many things
from my cooking from my dancing yeah
he's one to watch yes
and you think back to the days when you
first met mr. Sanchez on that phone call
chops and then they've chopped him so we
took them in half and portman yeah it's
about the kids I'm a cruel cheated to
the sorry minute not a 60-second hold on
I'm allowed to get prepped first this is
okay sorry ready ready right yes
time starts now all right let's go come
on Gordon no I want more peanut butter
let's go stop skipping on the peanut
bird a beautiful peanut butter and jelly
should have a nice like almost an eighth
of an inch of peanut butter should be
fluffy and generous it is fluffy no it's
not emails ago oh man
do you have to cut those in half hello
go all right we got 34 seconds left a
man of technique a man of 17 minutes are
you can look at this
what is that okay should be clapping
that's good it's fluffy
hello all right you got 20 seconds here
we go
oh my gosh I don't know I don't know if
you're gonna make it buddy come on let's
go 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 that's it hands
in the air hands in the air right all
right cool okay I make it good son let's
go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
no now are you ready yes hold on hold on
I'm gonna go one better I'm gonna cut
mine and I still do - no come on right
you ready $100 in for the winner all
right
9 to beat have you started please hold
on right hold on you know that's ok I'm
gonna fire your trainer let's go on your
mark get set go go
[Laughter]
we go
[Laughter]